Qu'est-ce que le cosplay ?
Une pratique où l'on ne doit faire qu'un avec notre personnage favori.
Être reconnaissable en un coup d'oeil.
Anis est... Afida Turner !
Greg est... C3PO !
Aurélien est... Dewey !
Seront-ils à la hauteur ?
Bonjour.
Excuse-moi ! D'après toi, je suis qui ?
Euh, je sais pas...
Alors à votre avis je suis en quel personnage ?
Euh, je sais pas.
J'ai un peu du mal.
Je reconnais pas du tout.
Un mec qui dort...
Avec un pyjama.
T'es sur la... T'es sur la bonne voie.
En peintre ?
Non.
T'es en marsupilami !
Breaking bad.
Non.
Madonna ?
Presque.
Plus culte encore.
En oeuf sur le plat.
Je vais te donner un indice.
Indice : c'est facile.
De quel manga à peu près ?
C'est plus une série et c'est plus la saison 2.
Loft story.
Ça ne me dit rien du tout, je suis vraiment désolée.
Je suis mignon. Pas moi, le personnage.
Michael Jackson.
Non plus.
Merde.
Je suis un enfant, j'ai les oreilles décollées, je suis mignon.
C'est dans un film.
W9.
En plusieurs épisodes.
Shneck !
Je vois pas du tout.
C'est... Shneck woman ?
C'est un peu Shneck woman.
Une balle de tennis en...
T'as déjà vu une balle de tennis dans un film américain qui fait ça ?
Je te fais une petite danse.
Poupi poupi pou...
Dewey !
Dewey, putain !
Poupi poupi pou...
Non vraiment pas.
Ok, merci quand même.
Je suis Afida Turner putain !
Ça se voit ! Il y a pas que Sangoku hein !
C'était C3PO dans Star Wars.
Putain mais ouais.
Ouais.
Afida Turner mec !
Tu me regardes énervé ou tu me regardes gentiment ?
Blasé on va dire...
Cool.
Putain mais pourquoi les gens nous reconnaissent pas ? C'est incroyable ça !
C'est pas le meilleur C3PO que t'as vu de tout les temps ?
Si.
On dirait... On dirait tellement C3PO, je comprends pas.
On dirait pas Afida Turner ?
Si on dirait vachement Afida Turner...
Mais juste le petit hic c'est qu'Afida Turner c'est pas hyper univers geek et tout, tu vois...
Je me disais si on se mettait en personnage de manga...
Les gens ils reconnaitraient plus.
Peut-être.
D'accord mais on fait quel manga ?
Je sais.
On a qu'à faire le meilleur manga de tout les temps.
Est-ce que vous avez le meilleur manga de tout les temps ?
Mais bien sûr.
Totally Spies ?
On est qui ?
Les Totally Spies ?
Yes !
Totally Spies.
On est les Totally Spies.
Totally... Spies !
Incroyable, tout le monde nous reconnait.
Ils l'ont fait.
A force d'abnégation.
Ils ne font plus qu'un avec les Totally Spies.